[Musik]
zwei Kinder 12 und 13 Jahre alt haben
die 12 Jahre alte Luise erstochen Kinder
töten wie kann das sein das fragen wir
uns hier in dieser Sendung und für große
Schlagzeile sorgt wieder mal Karl
Lauterbach er gibt jetzt zu ja es gibt
schwere Impfschäden und wie sicher ist
eigentlich noch unsere Energieversorgung
geht es tatsächlich ohne Atomkraft es
gibt also vieles zu besprechen heute
hier bei 8:15 Uhr mit diesem Gästen
Journalist Frank über den sagt
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach ist
in seinem Amt überfordert und sollte
zurücktreten es ist Zeit für Reformen
doch wir fragen uns wie weit wird die
katholische Kirche gehen lasst uns nicht
nur über Reformen sondern auch wieder
mehr über Gott reden das sagt Theologe
Psychiater und vatikanberater dr manfred
Lütz
mit Chefreporter Frank Schneider ist
schwer besorgt immer mehr Gewalt und die
Täter die werden immer jünger so wie
jetzt das Kinder ein Kind töten das
heißt tieferschreckend und ein
wahnsignal jetzt sind wir als
Gesellschaft insgesamt gefordert der
rheinland-pfälzische CDU-Chef Christian
Baldauf sieht schwarz wie die Industrie
und damit auch für uns Bürger ohne
Atomkraft gingen bei uns weil die
Lichter aus heftigen Streit gibt es auch
in Wuppertal dort soll ein links
alternatives Zentrum Platz machen für
eine die tippmaschine 6000 Quadratmeter
für Gebetsräume eine Kita und auch
Wohnheime für Senioren und Studenten im
Stadtrat stimmte eine Mehrheit von CDU
FDP Grünen und in Teilen auch der SPD
für den Neubau Kritiker wie z.B die
Politikwissenschaftlerin Susanne
Schröter laufen Sturm sie sagen es ist
ein Skandal dass die Stadt Wuppertal
ausgerechnet diesen Verein der als
verlängerte Arm des türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan gilt beim Bau
unterstützt die Moscheen von Dietz würde
zu aufgerufen und Antisemitismus
gepredigt Frank du kennst die Szene sind
die Parteien dort vor Ort naiv ich
glaube leider muss man sagen ja sie sind
naiv die Stadt möchte den Stadtteil
aufwerten möchte dort auch baulich
vieles verändern diese Straße wo die
Moschee jetzt gebaut werden soll ist
wirklich ein Schandfleck das muss man
auch so sagen und die Stadt wollte das
Aufwerten und hat jetzt die große
Hoffnung weil natürlich die Gemeinde
Geld mitbringen das bringt uns was aber
man vergisst eben dass sie die
tippgemeinde das haben wir auch leider
in Köln gesehen mit dieser großen
Moschee wo er am Anfang ja auch sehr
viel Kooperation da war sehr viel
gemeinsam war auch Anwohner auch dafür
waren hat sich das kurz nachdem sie
gebaut war hat wurde der Vorstand
ausgetauscht und dann ging es plötzlich
rückschrittlich zu in dieser Moschee ich
war damals beim Erdogan Besuch selber
dort vor Ort und hat das auch vor Ort
erlebt wie türkische Sicherheitskräfte
mehr oder weniger die Straßen übernommen
haben sie haben dann für Sicherheit
gesorgt das war ihre Straßen also
wirklich haben Ansprüche gestellt auch
muss man sagen an diesen Stadtteil in
Köln und eine Entwicklung die droht
jetzt auch in Wuppertal und in Wuppertal
gibt es noch eine Besonderheit an dieser
Straße schräg gegenüber ist das Autonome
Zentrum der linksautonom und die sind
jetzt so ein bisschen in der Zwickmühle
auf der einen Seite wollen rechte
Gruppen keine Großmoschee aber die
Linken wollen sie jetzt auch nicht weil
sie sagen dafür kommen wir unter die
Räder das Autonummer Zentrum soll
abgeschafft werden soll abgerissen
werden für diese Gemeinde und da ist
wirklich glaube ich ganz großer Streit
vorprogrammiert und da muss man jetzt
mal abwarten ob der Stadtrat sich ist
vielleicht doch nur überlegt aber
genehmigt ist es jetzt erstmal glauben
dass man dazu wenig Rücksicht nimmt dass
die Kommunen zu wenig Rücksicht nehmen
von Schneider sagt der ist eigentlich
schon vorprogrammiert bevor es überhaupt
losgeht ja eine spannende Frage bei die
Tipps zum Beispiel gab es ja viel lernen
damals ich weiß nicht wie die Situation
heute ist ob man sich da irgendwo
arrangiert hat oder nicht und ähm ich
denke das Grundproblem ist irgendwo
müssen natürlich auch eine
Religionsgemeinschaft ihre Kirche oder
ihre Moschee haben und ich denke mir
dann sollte das
im Grunde auch im Konsens erledigt
werden soll ein Thema weil die sind nun
mal da und früher waren halt Moscheen
meistens sind irgendwelchen Hinterhöfen
oder sonst wo und das kann ja nicht die
der Umgang mit einer Religion sein
Deutschland gleichzeitig ist die frage
werden hier in der Sendung auch
existieren müssten ihr fanpagei
beispielsweise zu Gast Herr Waldorf und
der hat davor gewarnt dass man oft das
vor allem die Politik auch ihre Partei
der in Wuppertal dafür gestimmt zu naiv
mit die Tipps umgeht stimmen Sie zu
ja ich kann jetzt auch nicht sagen was
die Beweggründe waren wahrscheinlich die
Aufwertung des Gebietes
die Tipps die Annett von Atatürk
eingeführt eine ganz klare verlängerte
Version dessen was in der Türkei
Regierungshandeln darstellt und das ist
im Moment Erdogan das war auch schon
anders aber es ist jetzt nun mal Erdogan
und wie er sich recht staatlich verhält
das wissen wir hier wir haben ja
natürlich im Islam sowieso das Problem
es gibt ja nur die Gemeinden ist ja
nicht wie bei den Katholiken und den
Protestanten man hat ganz viele
verschiedene von den mini-girls bis zu
äh die ja alle Ihre Ansprüche erheben
und ich glaube wenn man die
Religionsfreiheit auch in Deutschland
ernst meint dann muss man nicht nur die
Worte derer die diese Moscheen errichten
wollen wegen sondern auch das was sie
darin tun und wer es da tut und da ist
natürlich vor allem auffällig gerade in
Köln und auch außen rum dass die sehr
intensiv versuchen auch gegen unser
System zu arbeiten und deshalb hätte ich
mir gewünscht dass das Wuppertal so
nicht läuft wir haben in Rheinland-Pfalz
eine klare Meinung wir reden mit die
Tipp nicht also hat die CDU zumindest in
Wuppertal dazu sehr gekuscht ja man
müsste jetzt die Details sehen warum das
so gelaufen ist ich empfehle einfach nur
immer wir müssen wirklich aufpassen dass
man sich erstmal kundig macht erstmal
informiert das heißt ja nicht dass ich
jetzt damit Recht habe aber die Dinge
die ich sage sind ja nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs da gibt es ganz viele andere
Dinge die man auch zu hinterfragen hat
die Dialog zu führen auch mit die die ja
nicht macht sind ja klar aber bevor ich
dann ein solches Gebäude errichte und
vielleicht auch im Kontext mit den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern die dort wohnen
meine jetzt mal wusste nicht die Links
radikal und sonstige das sage ich gleich
dazu aber das muss ja in einem Konsens
funktionieren damit die Gesellschaft
nicht sondern trifft wie gesagt die Tipp
ist keine für mich klassische
Religionsgemeinschaft das ist ein
verlängerter Abend der türkischen
Regierung gleichzeitig werden mit 2.800
moscheene helles in der Deutschland und
natürlich
muss das Gebetsräume geben es werden
auch immer mehr und man kann verstehen
dass die Menschen gerade sie auch als
Theologe einen Ort brauchen wo sie beten
können ja das sehe ich auch man hat das
vielleicht ein bisschen zu gedankenlos
erstmal gemacht wie gesagt das wäre erst
im Hinterhof und so und das ist
natürlich nicht mehr angemessen wenn es
so viele Menschen gibt die ja da auch
hingehen also unsere Kirchen stehen zum
Teil leer und die sind voll ja das ist
ja auch so eine Sache die einen
nachdenklich macht
ich finde manchmal ein bisschen
schwierig wenn man wenn man jetzt so
lokale Gegebenheiten kommentieren soll
ich kenne diese Verhältnisse in
Wuppertal nicht ich finde es auffällig
auch auffällig dass die lokalen Parteien
die demokratischen Parteien einer
Meinung sind in dieser Frage da müssen
sie sich auch irgendwas bei denken ja
die werden ja sonst noch nicht mal
wieder gewählt wenn ihre eigene Leute da
Sturm laufen nachher also ich bin immer
dafür nur dann etwas zu solchen
konkreten Sachen zu sagen wenn man auch
genau informiert ist und das bin ich
einfach nicht also ich kann zu der
Wuppertaler Situation aber nicht sagen
aber dass wir das Problem lösen müssen
das ist Moscheen geben soll und ich
finde das ist zum Beispiel wichtig wäre
es wird immer gesagt aber ich glaube es
wird nicht umgesetzt das in Moscheen zum
Beispiel Deutsch gepredigt wird dann
indem man das hört das ist ja eine Frage
der Integration und gerade in diesem
Bereich finde ich ist es ein Problem
wenn sozusagen importierte Imame aus der
Türkei kommen kann wird Deutsch sprechen
und dann irgendetwas auf türkisch
erzählen was ja vielleicht ganz okay ist
ja aber es hat die Anmutung für Menschen
die kein Türkisch können dass da
irgendetwas hinter unserem Rücken
erzählt wird was möglicherweise auch
problematisch ist also das ist immer
wieder passiert im Zusammenhang mit die
Tipp es gab Antisemitismus Vorwürfe es
gab durchaus auch Predigten genau das
ist eben
überprüfen gerade sagt ist dann haben
wir eigentlich Nachholbedarf das muss
man auch machen und es hat keinen Zweck
jetzt weil jeder die die Moschee
sozusagen wieder reflexartig irgendwie
was zu sagen man müsste das Problem
eigentlich etwas grundlegender angehen
warum
warum reden sie nicht
bei uns in Rheinland-Pfalz haben die
sich in mehreren Diskussionsrunden die
wir mit ihnen hatten nicht klar
distanziert von der Vorgehensweise die
Erdogan vor Jahren vor allem im
Justizbereich an den Tag gelegt hat bei
der Frage des Putsches bei der Frage der
menschenrechtsgestaltung in deren
Gefängnissen also wir haben das sehr
explizit gezielt auch nachgefragt und
ich will Ihnen da recht geben gerade
solche
ja solche Gebetshäuser die ja nicht nur
den Islam betreffen auch das Judentum
Christentum ja bei uns sind die eher
leer aber es gibt auch noch viele andere
Bereiche bei denen muss ich ja
voraussetzen dass sie sich auf dem Boden
unserer Verfassung bewegen und dann muss
ich das natürlich auch bei die Typ tun
wenn die mir dann aber sagen das ist
alles so in Ordnung und ich habe da
meine Zweifel dann reden wir nicht damit
was nicht heißt dass wir uns auch
richtig verstehen dafür sind wir
Demokraten dass das für immer so sein
muss aber das erwarte ich schon dass man
das auch klar
da entstehen Wohnräume für Senioren
beispielsweise befürchten sie das dann
in in diesem Kreise fast wie so eine Art
Parallelgesellschaft entsteht das ist
jetzt die nächste Frage die sich oft
stellt so solche Dinge werden ja auch
begleitet von Verwaltungen und
Jugendämtern und anderen da hängt es im
Wesentlichen davon ab wie stark die
Kommune die Gemeinde jetzt auch
ausgestattet ist was sie leisten kann
was sie auch nachvollziehen kann da muss
ich jetzt offen aber dazu sagen wenn es
freie Träger gibt für Kindertagesstätten
von denen ich viel halte im übrigen auch
kirchliche Träger dann muss man die auch
machen lassen wenn sie sich auf dem
Boden unserer Grundsätze bewegen nur
weil die Typ habe ich da eben so meine
Probleme und deshalb muss man danach
schauen und wenn sie am Ende des Tages
aber das genauso machen wie es
pädagogisch und Erzieher
erziehungswissenschaftlich richtig ist
ja warum dann nicht
ich hoffe dass sonst dürfte man es nicht
zulassen und nicht genehmigen will
vielleicht noch mal sagen zu den
hinterhofmaschinen das natürlich völlig
richtig und auch wichtig dass man aus
diesen Hinterhöfen rausgekommen ist denn
das waren ja die brutbetten auch für
Terroristen und für wirklich Islamisten
das ist jetzt bei DITIB nicht so aber
was bei Detlef das Problem ist wir haben
es ja gerade gehört das ist eine
staatliche Einflussnahme und es ist ein
integrationshemmnis weil natürlich
Erdogan nicht möchte dass die Menschen
hier wirklich ankommen sich integrieren
das hat er ja auch selber mal gesagt
wenn er seine Reden hält auch in
Deutschland im Wahlkampf man muss das
wissen die Türken in Deutschland sind
für eine ganz riesige wichtige
Wählergruppe und er will ganz bewusst
sie haben die Wahl gewonnen Mann er hat
mit denen die Wahl gewonnen und er will
sie an sich binden und deshalb brauchte
diese großen Moscheen werden das ja in
Duisburg Marxloh genauso und er braucht
diese Moscheen um die deutschen Türken
sozusagen an sich gebunden zu halten und
er hindert sie mehr oder weniger auch
ich sag mal endgültig richtig anzukommen
weil er das nicht will er wird es Ihnen
sogar vor war von Assimilation und
ähnlichem wenn man sich hier integriert
und das finde ich halt das Problem also
das geht jetzt nicht um Brutstätten für
Terroristen oder ähnliches das ist das
ist Quatsch aber es geht wirklich darum
es ist ein ganz klares
integrationshemmnis und es entstehen
dann immer wieder Zentren die eigentlich
mehr oder weniger ihr eigenes Leben
führen mehr wie es der türkische Staat
sieht ja aber das ist doch genau mein
meine frage ich verstehe nicht diesen
diese ich habe die Kritik an die Tipps
natürlich staatsorganisationen Türkei
das Thema hätten wir auch schon vor 20
Jahren diskutieren können ist alles
nichts neues oder noch früher aber das
Grundproblem ist doch oder so das ist
überhaupt kein Austausch gibt zwischen
den unterschiedlichen ethnischen Gruppen
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland also
die Türken Leben für sich die Deutschen
Leben für sich und weiße Teufel was
alles und eigentlich müssen wir doch in
einem kritischen Diskurs gehen wo wir
den auch ganz klar die Meinung sagen
dass wir davon halten das heißt also
eben nicht irgendwelche
verfassungsschutzrechtlichen
Überlegungen zu machen mit wem reden wir
oder mit dem reden wir nicht sondern sie
sollen ihre Meinung haben aber die
müssen sich dann offensiv damit
auseinandersetzen also ich kenne sehr
viele Leute die auch sehr viele die
katholische Kirche kritisieren ich weiß
nicht ob das der katholischen Kirche
immer gefällt aber so laufen nun mal
Diskussion und unseren Gesellschaften
kann ich Ihnen nur Recht geben und das
wiederum muss man natürlich hat er
natürlich wieder recht weil wir
Wuppertal jetzt nicht genau kennen was
der Grund ist ich habe heute das muss
man natürlich auch vor Ort machen das
ist richtig ich werde jetzt so ganz
vielen Fasten brechen eingeladen da gehe
ich auch hin ja auch zu milikarisch die
sind zum Beispiel zum Teil vom
Verfassungsschutz bei unseren
Rheinland-Pfalz bis vor zehn Jahren noch
überprüft worden trotzdem gehe ich hin
und was mache ich da genau das was Sie
sagen ich frage wieso Predigt der jetzt
nicht deutsch
solche Dinge frage ich dann und dann
überlege ich mir wieso gibt es auch in
Deutschland so wenige Lehrstelle dafür
zu wenige Möglichkeiten die auch hier
auszubilden da muss man aber umgekehrt
auch erwarten dass die dann bereits in
ihren Moscheen diejenigen dafür zu
nehmen und ich glaube das ist politische
Aufgabe sich ähm möchte dem
widersprechen was sie gerade gesagt
haben man muss sie dann mal
konfrontieren und so
aus psychologischen Gründen ist so wenn
Sie eine Gruppe nur konfrontieren sie
noch stärker als Gruppe sich abschließen
das heißt es geht eigentlich darum dass
man im Grunde auch wertschätzend damit
umgeht ich kann mich erinnern ich war in
Duisburg Marxloh mal in der Moschee habe
da eine ich weiß nicht die hatte
Leitungsfunktion eine Frau kennengelernt
die durchaus sehr differenziert war und
da finde ich es eben ganz gut wenn man
guckt da ist jemand der es rein
staatstreu Türkisch und so weiter und da
ist jemand der versucht in unserem
Rahmen eine eine gewisse Freiheit sich
zu bewahren also da würde ich immer
dafür plädieren nicht pauschal die die
zu anzugreifen sondern sich genau die
Phänomene anzugucken und deswegen bin
ich auch zurückhaltend jetzt was zu
Wuppertal zu sagen weil Wuppertal ist
für uns Rheinländer sowieso kurz vor
Sibirien also ich bin links rein Länder
also Wuppertal ist
schon gar nicht wir haben auch gesagt
sie möchten über versprechen wo sie sich
wirklich auskennen und aus ihrer Sicht
traurigerweise kennen sie sich glaube
ich schon auch über die Gründe aus warum
Kirchenbänke sie haben das selbst gerade
gesagt immer Lehrer werden über dieses
Thema wollen wir gleich sprechen wir
wollen aber auch es liegt vorhin über
ihr neues Buch sprechen denn sie haben
mit dem künstlich verstorbenen Papst
Benedikt das letzte große Gespräch
geführt und haben einiges mitgenommen
aus diesem Gespräch einiges vielleicht
auch gelernt und einiges hier heute
mitgebracht dass Sie mit uns teilen
möchten es ist ihre Zeit ihre Kamera und
ihr Thema ja also es ist nicht das
letzte große Gespräch im Gegenteil das
Gespräch hat aber hier drauf auf jeden
Fall unser
letztes
Text auf so einem Cover da muss man aber
jedenfall
ja unser
letztes wahrscheinlich mit äh geführt
oder mit Papst franziskose also
es war so ich war in einer Talkshow bei
Markus Lanz und Markus Lanz hat mir
anschließend gesagt weil da wusste ich
habe da Kontakte im vatikaner auch Papst
Benedikt seit 40 Jahren er hätte
wirklich das große Anliegen noch einmal
Papst wenig zu bewegen habe den mal
interviewen das habe ihn zutiefst
berührt
oder habe ich im Team in die Augen
geguckt und gefragt meinst das wirklich
so und das meinte er wirklich so und
dann habe ich das organisiert dann war
mir aber 2018 eben er hat danach auch
nicht mehr sehr laut geredet aber es war
das letzte das letzte Gespräch haben wir
dann ein Gespräch mit ihm geführt und
wir hatten erst gar nicht beabsichtigt
das als Buch zu veröffentlichen dann war
es aber so überraschend was er sagt und
dann war es auch so beeindruckend was er
sagte das wäre gedacht haben das müssen
einfach dokumentieren und haben das dann
als Buch herausgegeben jetzt nach seinem
nach seinem Tod ähm bin ich der 16 unser
letztes Gespräch und ähm Markus Lanz hat
da finde ich sehr sehr sensibel noch mal
berichtet was er dafür einen Zugang hat
und ich habe aus meiner 40-jährigen
Erfahrung mit ihm berichtet und Markus
Lanz er hat auch mit Recht geschrieben
dass er kaum jemanden kennt wo das
öffentliche Image dem der Realität so
widerspricht also ist zum Beispiel einer
der humorvollsten Menschen die ich
überhaupt kenne der hat Spaß an Humor an
Ironie und so weiter
von morgens bis abends also sind
wirklich und geistreich natürlich immer
auch eine der gescheitesten Menschen die
ich kenne wenn ich den getroffen habe
dann hat er das Gespräch meistens da
fortgesetzt wo wir von einem Jahr
aufgehört haben das war mir immer ganz
unheimlich weil ich an meinem Gedächtnis
etwas gezweifelt habe aber er ist vor
allem und das muss man mal betonen ein
großer Theologe gewesen alles andere hat
eben nicht gerne gemacht er ist nicht
gerne Erzbischof von München gewonnen
hat Ersatzpflicht als religiöse Pflicht
auf sich genommen er ist nicht gerne
perfekte Glaubens Konjugation geworden
um Leuten zu sagen das geht aber nicht
und so oder er hat sich massiv mit
Händen und Füßen dagegen gewehrt
Johannes Paul II hat gesagt du musst
jetzt aber es geht nicht mehr und dann
hat er gesagt ich will wenigstens weiter
publizieren können das ist normalerweise
nicht üblich der perfekte Glauben
feststellen ob das katholisch oder nicht
und ich selber noch Bücher schreiben und
ähm ja dann vielleicht auch kritisiert
muss oder so sondern
er wollte weiter schreiben das hat er
auch gemacht und er und selbst seine
heftigsten Gegner bestreiten nicht dass
er nicht gerne Platz geworden ist er hat
das auf sich genommen und hat auch
selbst ganz offen geschrieben das hat er
uns auch gesagt ich habe gar keine
Fähigkeit für so einen Job ja
er ist ein großer Theologe er hat 1968
vor über 50 Jahren seinen ersten großen
Bestseller geschrieben die Einführung
des Christentum großer beste und ich
habe vor einem Jahr nachdem er das
Gespräch geführt haben ihn noch mal
gefragt ob ich eine Kurzfassung davon
machen kann von der Einführung des
Christentum so populär weil da sind auch
Anmerkungen und so das ist nichts für
nicht Wissenschaftler und dem hat er da
noch schriftlich zugestimmt dann habe
ich noch eine Kurzfassung gemacht ja
auch noch abprobiert die kommt jetzt im
Mai raus da kann man auf 250 Seiten
lesen was ist das Wesentliche des
Christentums und das ist ein bisschen
der Punkt den sie am Anfang Ansprachen
das halte ich für wichtig dass die
Menschen wieder wissen was ist das
entscheidende des Christentums das ist
nicht die Frage zu den Bart ja oder nein
da reden die Leute alle drüber also auf
meinem sterbe wird mich nicht die Frage
nach dem zu dem Bad interessieren sollen
die Frage Luthers wie bekomme ich ein
gnädigen Gott und darüber müssten aber
mehr reden in der Kirche also die Frage
existiert Gott das hat Ratzinger
interessiert darüber hat geschrieben es
gibt Menschen die durch dieses Buch die
einfach in das Christentum zum Glauben
gekommen sind und in diesen 250 Seiten
was ist das Christentum was ist das
wichtige des christentumsatz was das
bedeutet in der Nächstenliebe was das
bedeutet Toleranzen christliche
Erfindungen ja so das wissen die
Christen ja noch nicht mal das ist das
wesentlich und in diesem Buch sind
vielleicht drei Seiten drei vier Seiten
über die Kirche das muss man sich auch
mal klar machen ja wenn man denkt ja der
Ratzinger ist wir haben ihn gefragt ich
habe ihn gefragt wenn sie mal sie waren
beim Weltjugendtag in Köln ja 1 Million
Jugendliche ich habe das mal genau mir
durchgelesen sie haben keinen einzigen
Satz zur sexual Moral gesagt nicht sie
haben nur den Glauben die Schönheit des
Glaubens geredet übrigens Glauben an
Gott übernächsten Liebe bei Engagement
für Menschen in Not und so aber nichts
über Sex zu haben Moral ja ganz bald der
zweite hatte immer viel darüber geredet
vergleichsweise viel und er hat gesagt
das hat ihn auch nie sehr interessiert
ja aber dennoch sind auch von
Journalisten immer diese Themen an ihn
herangetragen worden sind jetzt für
dagegen Kondome und sowas und das war
eine Sache er war Theologe
heute Menschen die Schönheit des
christlichen Glaubens vermitteln und
dieser Text ist wirklich wenn man ihn
befreit auch von diesen
wissenschaftlichen Dingen das habe ich
dann gemacht wirklich ein funkelnder
Text mit mit tollen Formulierungen und
ich glaube wir als Deutsche könnten
eigentlich ein bisschen stolz darauf
sein dass er eigentlich der eine
vielleicht der wichtigste Theologe des
20 Jahrhunderts ist und wir haben den in
so kleine Schubladen getan dass man nur
noch über die Frage des Missbrauchs
redet nur noch über die Frage der
Sexualmoral da ist er in vielen Fällen
vielleicht nicht geschickt mit
umgegangen ich habe das selbst erlebt
allerdings Vatikan war Papst Benedikt
oder schon keine Ratzinger der
radikalste der gegen Missbrauch gekämpft
hat ich war bei einer bei einer
geheimtagung hat weil ich eingeladen
1999 mit dem Führerschein sozusagen mit
den Spitzen der Kurie und er war der
Einzige der klar gesagt hat nein diese
Priester wir müssen uns von den trennen
es geht nicht dass es so schrecklich ja
und die anderen sagten alle muss man
auch nicht so streng nehmen oder sowas
und das heißt dieser Mut dieses dieses
kleinen schmächtigen Mannes der hat mich
der hat mich schon sehr beeindruckt
deswegen finde ich die Art und Weise wie
dann damit umgegangen worden ist sehr
ungerecht ich habe dieses Münchner
Gutachten gelesen das ist einfach in dem
Punkt auch zum Teil zum Teil wertlos ja
die haben die haben 8000 Seiten
durchgekackert und haben kein einzigen
wirklichen Beweis dass er überhaupt was
wusste über solche Fälle da muss man
natürlich darüber diskutieren warum hat
man ihm das nicht gesagt hätte er nicht
seine Sache so organisieren müssen dass
die Leute ihm das sagen ja darüber kann
reden es gab keine Beweise und deswegen
finde ich und das ist auch Sinn dieses
Buch was ich mit Markus Lanz geschrieben
habe dass man Papst Benedikt mal wieder
in Deutschland entdeckt sozusagen
sehr herzlich von ihm muss man sagen und
ich glaube würden sie wahrscheinlich vor
vielen Jugendlichen so über entsprechend
kämpfen vielleicht bei dem ein oder
anderen erstmal die Frage auf dem Land
der klingt interessant der Mann über den
möchte ich mehr erfahren bittere
Wahrheit ist so ist es ja irgendwie
leider nicht und zwar mit der gesamten
katholischen Kirche derzeit sie haben es
angesprochen immer weniger Bänke sind
besetzt immer weniger vor allem von
jungen Menschen woran fehlt es da sie
haben gesagt natürlich wir haben übers
Personal sozusagen gesprochen aber
stimmt die Botschaft noch ist es eine
Botschaft die junge Menschen noch
erreicht also ich glaube dass die
Debatten die wir in Deutschland zum Teil
führen ich mache mich da gar nicht
lustig drüber Frage zu die Bart oder
Frauen diagonat oder sexual Moral Fragen
sind die viele Katholiken bewegen aber
ich habe zum Beispiel dafür plädiert die
katholische Kirche sollte ein
zehnjähriges Buch Schweigen zu sexuellen
Fragen einhalten sie sollte einfach die
den Mund halten
Klappe halten ich bin nicht Christ wegen
der Sexualmoral sondern ich bin Christ
weil ich an Gott glaube an Jesus
Christus habe und weil ich uneigennützig
Flüchtlingen anderen Menschen helfen
will und so das ist Sinn Sinn meines
christlichen Lebens und auch auf dem
Sterbebett wird mir nicht die
Sexualmoral interessieren ja sondern so
das heißt wir reden wir sind fixiert auf
diese Themen und das finde ich auch ein
Problem ich bin beim Weltjugendtag in
Madrid gewesen aber Papst Benedikt
damals und ich habe ich kann mich noch
gut erinnern ich stand da abends sah
eine Million Menschen aus der ganz junge
Menschen aus der ganzen Welt die diesen
Mann zujubelten und die begeistert waren
von dieser Zärtlichkeit dir so
ausstrahlte also das war berührend und
da habe ich mir überlegt 66 Jahre nach
dem schrecklichen Zweiten Weltkrieg wo
die deutschen diese diese Schrecken über
die Welt gebracht haben jubeln eine
Million jugendlich aus der ganzen Welt
diesen deutschen sie sagen es gibt sie
zumindest noch aber ich habe auch
schweres Atmen gehört bei Ihnen bei
Christian Waldorf Christian mit Vornamen
Mitglied der CDU aber Klappe zu jetzt
wird einfach mal geschwiegen
also bereitet
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das der
richtige Weg ist ich glaube die Analyse
zeigt bin selbst katholisch und das
wissen die allerwenigsten bis zur 10
Klasse wurde sogar selbst mal Priester
werden und sie ist dann nicht so
gekommen aus gewissen Gründen die man
halt herzlich schmunzeln aber ich glaube
das Problem ist woanders sie können das
in der jetzigen Phase in der sich die
katholische Kirche befindet und im
Übrigen auf die protestantische Kirche
übertragen wird da sind ja auch eine
ganze Menge Austritte drin können Sie
das nicht mehr stoppen ich glaube eher
es geht nur mit offenem Visier weil was
wenn sie jetzt beginnen nichts mehr zu
sagen wird ihnen das auch keiner
abnehmen ich sage nur wir müssen über
andere Themen reden junge Leute nicht
daran interessiert ja da gebe ich Ihnen
erzählt wie sie Sex machen sollen nein
das ist ja natürlich aber selbst
konservative Katholiken nicht die die
sagen immer am Abend vor der
Hochzeitsnacht noch mal den Papst
anrufen wollen was mache ich jetzt hat
der Vater oder die machen was sie was
sie richtig finden ja und aber auch
schon mal ja aber die Zahlen sind lang
vorbei hat
Autorität auch in Fragen der Sexualmoral
völlig eingebüßt wir können über die
Gründe reden aber das ist ja als wurscht
ich glaube wir müssen mehr über das
reden was ist der Sinn des Lebens also
leider haben sie Recht die Frage ja und
junge Leute haben die wir haben jetzt
über der über die jungen Kinder da
gesprochen wurde inzwischen jung und
Kinder andere jungen Kinder umbringen
oder so etwas wir müssen wieder Werte
vermitteln und dafür ist es wichtig
schon auch über den Glauben an Gott zu
reden über über und es gibt die etwas
bildenden Verbände sind nun mal die
Kirchen noch nicht die Tennisclubs nein
da haben Sie Recht und wenn man da
anschließt wäre mein Wunsch auch als
praktizierender Katholik es fehlt
pflichtweg das hat auch was mit der
Menge der Person zu tun die wir noch
haben es fehlt schlichtweg an der
Seelsorge weil sie ganz andere Probleme
im Moment zu meistern haben die sind
Verwaltungs technische Probleme andere
Dinge ich hätte mir übrigens mehr Mut
gewünscht das muss ich auch sagen es gab
ja mal einen Papst Johannes den 23 der
hat sehr sehr gute und sehr sehr
wegweisende Vorschläge gemacht das war
allerdings allerdings in den 70ern und
in den 60er 60er Jahren vor allem die
sind halt nie so weit gekommen und dass
wir ich frage es mal eigentlich ich
sag's mal andersrum überhaupt darüber
diskutieren das Frauen da nicht in Frage
kommen dass wir überhaupt darüber
diskutieren dass nicht geheiratet werden
darf das ist kein Wunsch von Jesus
gewesen ist ein Konzil beschlossen
worden dass diese Dinge heute in der
Zeit in der die Seelsorge so wichtig
wäre das was sie sagen die
Wertevermittlung überhaupt so lange
diskutiert wenn du verstehe ich nicht
gelöst werden aber wir haben einen
speziell deutsches Problem natürlich wir
haben so eine deutsche Babbel und denken
die Themen auch das sind die wichtigsten
Themen es ist in Deutschland überhaupt
nicht aufgefallen dass Papst franziskus
vor einem halben Jahr das
Kardinalskollegium abgeschafft hat de
facto das hat keiner gemacht ja Papst
franziska hat vor von einem halben Jahr
entschieden dass das
tausend Jahre lang war das der Senats
waren die führenden Berater des Papstes
und jetzt können alle führenden Behörden
des Vatikan von Frauen geleitet werden
das steht noch nicht mehr in der Zeitung
ja das frage ich mich auch warum
das kann man im Internet auch nachlesen
ja das heißt Nachfolgerin von von
Kardinal Ratzinger als perfekt der
glaubenskongation kann nächsten Monat
eine Frau werden wo steht das bitte in
der Zeitung und ich finde wir müssten
mal von dir und wir diskutieren im Sinne
der Weg wird über das Frauen Diakonat
geredet Diakonie heißt dienen ja dann
wird sozusagen die dienstfunktion der
Frau auch noch sakralisiert ich finde
das keinen Riesenfortschritt und dann
kann die Frau am Ende der heiligen Messe
sagen geht hin in Frieden ich finde es
ist wichtiger dass Frauen mehr Macht in
der Kirche haben und nicht über die
Weihe Ämter glaube ich läuft das und das
ist auch glaube ich die Strategie von
Papst franziskus sondern darüber dass
dass die Kleriker Macht abgeben an Leim
an Leute wie sie und da ist es höchste
Zeit da werden ja über den glauben Sie
dass man Jugendliche überhaupt noch für
solche Themen begeistern kann wie tief
steckt die Kirche aus ihrer Sicht in der
Krise ja ich bin ja ich bin evangelisch
seit Geburt und ich bin da Zahlen des
Mitglied ums mal so auszudrücken und
letztlich glaube ich dass wir in einer
säkularen Gesellschaft reden also um es
mal ein bisschen zuzuspitzen man könnte
auch sagen die katholische Kirche ist
eine Art helles Club wo sich nur noch
die Tennisspieler für interessieren aber
ansonsten ist die ausstrahlungswirkung
in die Gesellschaft mittlerweile glaube
ich
äußerst reduziert um sich zuzuspitzen
und natürlich hat heute kein
Jugendlicher mehr interessiert sich
eigentlich dafür welche Meinung hat die
katholische Kirche zu sexuellen Fragen
zu Homosexualität oder so ich habe noch
niemand getroffen der sich in der
Beziehung an der katholischen Kirche
relevant genau aber was da natürlich zum
Ausdruck kommt wir haben gerade über den
Islam gesprochen und über Moscheen
offensichtlich haben wir ein
spirituelles Defizit
und wir müssen reden ja darüber muss man
gerne reden also ich bin
dieses Defizit wird glaube ich zum Teil
in solchen Bewegungen wie letzte
Generation auch schon ganz Generationen
kompensiert oder so das hat ja auch sehr
viel spirituelle quasi religiös aber
Religion eine neue quasi ja das bekommt
natürlich dann das ist ja auch nicht
alles ganz neu also zum Beispiel 20er
Jahren der Marxismus der hatte auch
schon so etwas sektenartiges und so aber
was ich wirklich ähm was sie wirklich
bezweifle ist ob die katholische Kirche
selber intern das was sie so schön in
ihrem Buch jetzt auch beschreiben wollen
ob sehr viele Katholiken das überhaupt
noch wissen das heißt also die eigenen
Überzeugung die eigene Ideologie die
eigene ideologischen Grundlagen
religiösen theologischen Grundlagen sind
glaube ich vielen Katholiken heute gar
nicht mehr klar
es geht um die Gesellschaft insgesamt
ich habe in Weimar ich will das nur mal
sagen ich habe den Weimar bei der
gesamten Oberstufe 300 atheistische
Oberstufen Schüler ein Vorteil gehalten
über Gott ja ich habe mein Buch
geschrieben Gott eine kleine Geschichte
das größte habe ich auch Kabarett zu
gemacht und habe da geredet es war eine
der spannendsten Diskussionen die ich
geführt habe die waren alle interessiert
die Frage was ist der Sinn des Lebens
warum lebe ich eigentlich ja gibt es
sowas wie eine letzte Instanz ob man die
jetzt Gott nennt oder nicht das ist auch
für junge Menschen interessant aber
unsere in kircheninternen Debatten ja
die arkone oder oder was weiß ich oder
oder Sexualmoral oder sogar sagen die
also Opa g ja also das interessiert mich
ja aber spirituelle Fragen finde ich
auch evangelischen Kirche zum Beispiel
er weiß gar nicht fragen nein nein nein
der ist Frau kessmann z.B die schreibt
Bestseller eine nach dem anderen wenn
sie überzeugend auch spirituelle Fragen
beantworten dann dann kommen die Leute
auch junge Menschen also unsere Töchter
wir haben 45 Jugendliche bei uns über
zehn Jahre immer eingeladen da haben die
so so Reli Campen nannte sich das vier
vier Tage lang und die sind inzwischen
die gehen alle immer noch in die Kirche
sind fromm aber ziemlich feierfreudig
also nicht verklemmt das heißt das geht
ja aber man muss den Mut haben das dann
auch zu machen und ich finde Christen
auch in unserem Alter müssen sich dann
vielleicht auch mal bekennen ja das tun
wir ja eigentlich nicht die katholischen
Tradition wir beide schonen
das ist aber sozusagen katholisch auch
nicht üblich also katholisch ist man
einfach selbstverständlich und da redet
man nicht dauernd über seinen Glauben
weil wir aber vor 30 Jahren darüber auch
nicht haben reden müssen also völlig
normal war natürlich in unserem Alter
jetzt feststellen dass es eben nicht
mehr aber
auch machen
ich würde sagen genau
vielleicht ein spirituelles Defizit hat
er da stellte sich solche Fragen sind er
sich nach sowas ist für ihn die Kirche
überhaupt noch irgendwie interessant im
biblischen Sinne muss ich jetzt mal
Wasser in den Wein gießen das klingt
alles wunderbar und auch das spirituelle
sicherlich was ganz wichtiges aber das
interessiert junge Menschen erst dann
wenn natürlich etwas ausgesendet wird
und das tut die Kirche nicht das hat ihn
der corona-krise nicht wo war die Kirche
denn der corona-krise ich bin selber
Katholik die Kirche bemüht überhaupt
nicht und
Sexualmoral darum geht es nicht aber
diese missbrauchsgeschichten und sie
sagen auf der einen Seite das Gutachten
sagt naja der Papst wusste ja gar nichts
auf der anderen Seite sagen sie in dem
geheimzirkel hat er gesagt das muss
aufhören die müssen weg diese Priester
Moment aber er hat dann auch was gemacht
ich habe 2003 den erst mit Ratzinger
zusammen den ersten vatikanischen
missbrauchskongress organisiert ist auch
publiziert worden weil er das wollte
also wir haben eine Debatte geführt ja
auch eine wissenschaftliche Debatte
darüber das was er halt tun konnte aber
sagen wir mal so Missbrauch ich finde
Missbrauch durch katholische Priester
und ordentlich schlimmer als jeder
anderen missbraucht ist die die jungen
Leute verlieren ja nicht nur das
Vertrauen in Menschen auch das Vertrauen
in Gott und deswegen ist die Kirche
besonders betroffen dadurch ich glaube
das was wir in Deutschland machen als
Missbrauch Aufarbeitung der
Bischofskonferenz weitgehend ehrlich
gesagt gescheitert ist ja also
ich plädiere seit zehn Jahren schon
dafür eine staatliche Untersuchung zu
machen katholische Kirche evangelische
Kirche deutsche olympischen und dann
kann man systemische Ursachen zum
Beispiel wissenschaftlich seriös
feststellen im Vergleich im Moment gibt
es wissenschaftlich seriös die reden
zwar dauernd von systemischen Ursachen
aber das ist sozusagen das was jeder so
als lieblingsursache hat aber
wissenschaftliche Daten gibt es gar
nicht und die hätte ich gerade will ich
gerade was zu sagen das ist immer alles
sehr theoretisch Kongress und
wissenschaftlich an der Basis fragen Sie
mal die Ermittlungsbehörden wie die
Kirche sich versperrt hat die haben
Priester einfach versetzt haben nicht
Bescheid gesagt haben sie in eine andere
Gemeinde geschickt dort haben sie erneut
Kinder missbraucht und die haben mit den
Ermittlungsbehörden nie kooperiert und
wenn ich dann gehört aber ich kann sagen
ich war Katholik ich bin genau deshalb
ausgetreten von zwei Jahren ich habe
gesagt nein dafür bezahl ich kein Geld
mehr ich spende dieses Geld was ich
jetzt sparen die SOS Kinderdorf und das
ist besser aufgehoben als bei der Kirche
weil ich habe gehört dass ein Kardinal
sich beraten lässt von PR-Agentur und
wir am besten aus diesen Affären
rauskommen und dafür gehen
Kirchensteuern drauf und fragen Sie mal
in den Gemeinden da sind kirchendächer
undicht da kommt kein Geld von Bistum da
sind Kindergärten die kein Geld haben da
werden Kindergärten geschlossen weil das
Seniorenheim mehr Geld bringt ja und
dann wunder ich mich dass kein Nachwuchs
mehr also wir sind in dem gar nicht
unterschiedlicher machen also Sie haben
ja vielleicht gemerkt dass ich die
Bischöfe nicht besonders verteidigt habe
aber ich glaube also ich bin nicht in
die Kirche eingetreten wegen Bischöfen
ich trete doch nicht aus wegen Bischöfen
die völlig überfordert sind mit der
Situation glaube ich auch aber ich
glaube angesichts der Tatsache das ist
eine wertekrise gibt in dieser
Gesellschaft ja und dass man jungen
Menschen nicht einfach sagen können ja
Konsum bis zum Abwinken oder so ich habe
Drogenabhängige behandelt und so die
einfach sagen es ist sinnlos ich habe
einen jungen Menschen auf der
Intensivstation gehabt der der Wacht aus
dem Koma auf der hatte versucht sich mit
Tabletten das Leben zu nehmen und sagt
Herr Doktor was ist für Sie der Sinn des
Lebens ja und dann habe ich mit ihm über
meinen Glauben gesprochen und nachher
einen Kollegen geschickt damit er auch
noch mal die ärztliche Untersuchung
macht das heißt wir müssten eigentlich
den Fokus auf andere Themen legen ja ich
glaube die innerkirchlichen Themen sind
einfach ausgereizt ja das aber dann
müssen wir auch eines tun und da war
nicht ein wenig vor weil sie sagen es
kann so ein bisschen ja bei den SOS
Kinder davon ist es besser angelegt
jetzt liegt es mir fern ich zahle auch
ordentlich Kirchensteuer also meine Frau
auch evangelisch also für beide
so unsere Kinder waren in einer
evangelischen Kindertagesstätte und da
wurden zumindest in den frühesten Zeiten
Gebete andere Dinge mit vermittelt so
ich glaube schon dass man alleine nicht
immer nur sagen kann die wollen das
alles schließen und ähnliches die der
Druck der da entsteht auch bei den
Kosten ist natürlich auch enorm und er
müsste man wenn man die Kirchen stärken
will denen auch aufgeben zu sagen gerade
in diesen Bereichen ja der der Erziehung
der Bildung anderer Dinge da braucht ihr
mehr Standkraft und wenn ihr das lasst
ihn euren Schulen in euren Kitas mit den
ganz normalen wertevermittlungen hätten
wir wesentlich mehr gewonnen was
passiert denn im Moment in den Schulen
da gibt's dann Ethik
evangelischen oder katholischen
Unterricht bekommen
ja aber ich finde was ist denn das
Besondere an der katholischen Kirche ich
bewundere die katholische Kirche
allerdings nicht wegen ihrem
Missionsauftrag den sie ja da
formulieren in einer technischen
Gesellschaft und zwar Spitzen sondern
ich bewundere die katholische Kirche
dafür dass sie es Institution
anderthalb 2000 Jahre fast überlebt und
warum hat sie als Institution überlebt
ja nicht nur weil sie dann internes
Fundament hatte sondern weil sie es
geschafft hat als Institution der
Weltkirche zu sein ich glaube das ist
auch der eigentliche Hintergrund vom
Zölibat dass meine verhindern will dass
die Kirchen auseinanderfallen in so
einer Art Familienbetriebe wo dann der
Vater auf den Sohn vererbt das gab es ja
alles in der Kirche Geschichte schon mal
das war glaube ich der ursprüngliche
Hintergrund und
das ist jetzt die Frage ob diese
Institution Kirche wenn sie Sinn
entleert selber ist also ihren
Missionsauftrag nicht mehr erfüllt in
einer säkularen Gesellschaft
ob sie dann als Institution eigentlich
ohne zusammenfällt und das ist ja genau
der Punkt also natürlich ist die Kirche
zum Beispiel ist ein gigantischer
Arbeitgeber ein große weite Teile
unseres Wohlfahrtsstaates werden über
Kirchen abgeregelt da gab es immer die
diskussionskirchliche Arbeitsrecht das
hat allerdings mit der katholischen
Nächstenliebe oder sonst irgendetwas wie
relativ wenig zu tun das sind das sind
Institutionen die Einrichtung betreiben
und die Einrichtungen müssen am Ende mit
plus minus 0 abschließen und diese
Trägerschaften zum Beispiel von
Kindergärten das ist ja nur formal will
eigentlich auch wollen viele katholische
Gemeinden das gar nicht mehr machen
und ja gut aber findet halt kein anderer
letzte Frage weitere 2000 Jahre schafft
das die Kirche wird dass sie so lange
noch geben aber das hat er eben sehr gut
gesagt es ist tatsächlich die einzige
Institution die 2000 Jahre bestanden hat
und das hat sie geschafft auch in ganz
schlimmen Krisen natürlich geschafft in
dem sich immer auch wieder verändert hat
und wirklich die neue Zeit sich
angeguckt und ich fand so wie Papst
franziskus angetreten ist der wird
natürlich auch jetzt kritisiert ist ja
okay ja aber ich glaube vieles von dem
was er gemacht hat auch die kurienreform
die ich eben genannt habe die Art und
Weise wie er Flüchtlinge in den
Mittelpunkt gestellt hat wir nach
Lampedusa gefahren ist wir auch
ökologisch bei der Klimakatastrophe sich
sich engagiert das finde ich wichtig
dass wir eben nicht nur globale Konzerne
haben die ökonomisch erfolgreich sind
Google Amazon und so sondern das ist
eine einzige Institution gibt es gibt
der der Islam ist auch eine Weltregion
aber das ist nicht eine Institution ist
ja schon in Deutschland schwierig
aber das ist eine Institution gibt die
das zusammenhält das finde ich und da
finde ich manchmal müssten wir Deutschen
auch eine etwas weniger sage ich mal nur
auf Deutschland konzentrierte Sichtweise
haben wir haben jetzt diskutiert beim
Synodalen Weg zum Beispiel über die
Frage der Segnung von homosexuellen
Partnerschaften das kann man diskutieren
okay bekommen beim
sinusweg aber es kann dazu führen das
war aber gar nicht im Blick ist ein
komischerweise auch nicht gefragt das
einige afrikanische Priester jetzt nicht
mehr mit deutschen katholische Priester
nicht mehr mit deutschen Priestern
zusammen Messe feiern werden weil in
afrikanischen Ländern ist es zum Teil
gibt's die Todesstrafe der Papst hat
sich jetzt gegen die Todesstrafe für
Homosexuelle eingesetzt in Afrika und
hat Gegenwind bei den Katholiken auch
bekommen also nicht sehr aber immerhin
das heißt wenn wir mal so global denken
ist die Frage warum Sexualität finde ich
wo konservative Katholiken in
Deutschland und progressive Katholiken
sich einnehmen könnten die Frage der
Todesstrafe für Homosexuelle dass man
sich dagegen mal einsetzt und bei der
Frage die Römer ich kenne das ja so ein
bisschen wie die man dann über die
deutschen reden die sagen auch Segnung
von homosexuellen Partnerschaften da
macht es doch ja müsst ihr immer eine
Erlaubnis von uns Römern haben müsste es
immer schriftlich aber wir wollen es
immer dann schriftlich haben und dann
auch selber loben dass wir das so
durchsetzen und das kann auch zu
tatsächlich zu Verwerfungen in der
globalen Kirche führen und da finde ich
den Wert dass es diese Kirche universal
gibt schon sehr hoch ja das wird auch
nicht in Deutschland glaube ich so ich
nehme das ja nur am Rande somit ich habe
andere Themen aber ist glaube ich auch
nur eine diese deutsche spezifische
Borniertheit das kann man ja wirklich
sagen dass sie eigentlich nicht mehr
über den eigenen Tellerrand
hinausschauen weil weil z.B nur ein
Beispiel dass sie mal irgendwann mal
gelesen habe für die katholische Kirche
in Brasilien ist ja eigentlich nur
katholisches Land und da haben es dann
wirklich amerikanische geschafft weite
Teile mit ihrem Missionsauftrag der
Bevölkerung zu sicher rüberzuziehen
ja aber das zeigt natürlich oder so wie
ähm welche Kraft sondern missionarische
Arbeit immer noch haben kann in einem
Volk was oder bei Menschen die
spirituelles und da werden sie ganz
katholisch an dieser Stelle
mein Stichwort jetzt für unser nächstes
Thema denn eigentlich wollen wir genau
das jetzt machen es geht viel um
Aufarbeitung wir wollen vor allem reden
über Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
denn der so glauben sie so nehmen sie an
wird nicht mehr unbedingt zu lange
seinen Job haben können Stichwort
Impfschäden da ist jetzt einiges
vorgefallen das ist ihr Thema ja ob Karl
Lauterbach noch weiterhin
Bundesgesundheitsminister wird das kann
ich natürlich nicht beurteilen also aber
wenn es um den Herren Grundsatz
politische Verantwortung für gewisse
Dinge geht dann müsste natürlich
irgendjemand in der deutschen Politik
mal endlich Verantwortung übernehmen ähm
das könnte theoretisch auch hier in
Spanien sein aber der ist ja bekanntlich
nicht mehr an sondern wurde mit ihrer
Partei abgewählt also der ist schon weg
da bleibt eigentlich nur der jetzige
Bundesgesundheitsminister über dich das
interessante am
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ist natürlich dieses
heute journal Interview am vergangenen
Sonntag das war ja ein Ergebnis einer
ZDF-Dokumentation über Impfschäden und
wo er dann tatsächlich gesagt hat er
hätte also über diese Impfschäden und
Impfnebenwirkungen schon die ganzen
Jahre über Bescheid gewusst das ist ja
nicht so dass er neu Erkenntnisse haben
kann das wollen wir niemand verweigern
aber Karl Lauterbach war der Prototyp
des des Mannes der eigentlich alles was
Impfschäden und ähnliche Dinge betraf
klein geredet hat dann finde ich nicht
und ähm ja darüber können wir dann
gleich reden und ähm und das ist genau
das das entscheidende Problem dass jetzt
auf einmal etwas aufploppt was schon
länger bekannt war und das zweite was
Karl Lauterbach eigentlich was mich noch
weiter erstaunte Karl Lauterbach hat er
ziemlich exakt gesagt also 1:10000 er
hatte irgendwo so eine Zahl genannt also
sehr gering ne sondern dass dann die
Mediziner auf welcher Datengrundlage er
das gemacht hat ist mir nicht ganz klar
weil eigentlich haben wir so eine
miserabel Datenlage dass wir sowohl dass
wir bei über Impfschäden oder gar nicht
richtig Auskunft geben können mit dem
was sie in Deutschland haben
einmal gemeinsam rein ins Heute das ging
vor allem auch um die Aussage er hätte
die Impfung als nebenwirkungsfrei
beschrieben was Karl Lauterbach heute
dazu sagte schauen
naja das war eine Übertreibung also die
ich da einmal in einem missglückten
Tweet gemacht habe aber es war ja nicht
grundsätzlich meine Haltung ich hatte ja
sehr sehr häufig vorher auch schon zu
den Nebenwirkungen der Impfungen
Stellung genommen sind zum Beispiel sehr
viel aber auch häufig danach noch gesagt
es gebe kaum oder praktisch gar keine
halt mehr oder weniger nebenwirkungsfrei
haben sie danach in der Fernsehsendung
von Anne Will noch mal gesagt ich habe
es ja eben gesagt also die Zahlen waren
mir ja die Zeit bekannt die sind auch
relativ stabil geblieben diese
Impfstoffe sind ja weltweit eingesetzt
worden 1 zu 10.000 das hätte also die
Zahl über 1:10.000 das ist jetzt hier
unser großes Thema der Umgang des
Gesundheitsministers mit den im Stehen
übrigens sie haben gerade eben gesagt er
hat da im Prinzip mehr oder weniger eine
riesenwende hingelegt er hat erst gesagt
es ist alles nebenwirkungsfrei und jetzt
gibt er etwas kompliziert dann doch zu
ja es gibt sie die impfen kann man sagen
er hat bewusst die ihre geführt ich weiß
gar nicht ob er das bewusst macht oder
sich selber einfach in ihre führt weil
das Groteske ist ja dass er jetzt
irgendwo etwas behauptet was seine
gesamten Kommunikationslinien in den
ganzen zwei Jahren komplett widerspricht
also ich habe zum Kollegen von der Welt
Tim rödenas haben wir damals zum
Beispiel darüber berichtet über eine
über die Daten der BKK Provita der hatte
die
betriebskrankenkassendaten ausgewertet
und der Kollege der Vorstandsvorsitz
oder der Vorsitzende dieser
Betriebskrankenkasse wollte dass da mit
dem paul Ehrlich Institut
diskutiert dazu ist gar nicht gekommen
der wurde entlassen aufgrund von
massiven Druck wie kann man überhaupt so
etwas machen wie kann man das in Frage
stellen das war schon das war schon das
einzige Argument das wäre querdenkerei
Geschwurbel und weiß der Teufel alles
ich kann mich ja diese Diskussion weil
ich habe mich ja daran ja selber aktiv
beteiligt ähm kann ich mich wirklich
noch sehr gut erinnern und jetzt kommt
Karl Lauterbach mit genau dieser These
und was wir damals zum Beispiel genauso
schon geschrieben haben das ist also
immer noch so wir haben deswegen so
schlechte Daten weil man am Beginn der
Pandemie folgendes hätte machen müssen
oder wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
rechtlich
Sozialgesetzbuch 5 Paragraf 295 also das
ist total wichtig übermittlungspflichten
und Abrechnung bei ärztlichen Leistung
dann hätten wir das damals zum Beispiel
bei jedem geimpften auf die
Krankenkassenkarte eingetragen der ist
geimpft oder nicht geimpft da hätten wir
bei gewissen Krankheitsbildern zum
Beispiel reale zahlen gehabt wie
entwickeln die sich bei geimpften wie
entwickeln die sich bei ungeimpften das
was wie beim paul-ehrlichen Institut
bekommen haben in den ganzen in diesen
zwei Jahren da kann jeder jetzt
irgendwie eine impf nehmenwirkung mehr
melden aber das Problem ist das ist
überhaupt keinen Ansatz noch niemand
statistischen Hinweis darauf gibt
ob das jetzt
epidemiologisch statistisch mit der
Impfung zusammen anstehen kann oder
nicht also im Grunde laufen wir im Nebel
herum und das ist natürlich der einzige
Skandal also dass wir überhaupt nicht in
der Lage sind aufzuklären und dann am
Beispiel wäre es besser macht die Ideen
zum Beispiel
es gab ja es gibt ja ein paar
Krankheiten die sind tatsächlich bekannt
also Myokarditis Sinus wie ein Thrombose
und so etwas bei astrasenica und was
machen Ideen als sie da das mitbekommen
haben aufgrund ihrer statistischen
Auswertung die funktioniert haben haben
astrasenica sofort vom handgemacht
genommen das war irgendwelche oder so
etwas 2021 die Deutschen haben es erst
im September gemacht aber ich würde
jetzt noch mal doch widersprechen also
erstens finde ich die die Argumentation
völlig absur sozusagen ja der Span hat
das damals falsch gemacht und jetzt muss
der Lauterbach dann deswegen
zurücktreten also entweder sparen oder
Lauterbach in der man muss den Kontext
sehen die damalige Situation war das
völlig idiotische Impfgegner diesen
aufgestellt haben die völlig absurd
waren und ich kann dir vorstellen dass
jemand wieder Lauterbach dann sagt gegen
diese hoch gefährlich und bloß nicht
impfen und so gesagt hat die ist
nebenwirkungsfrei jeder der sich
wissenschaftlich auskennt jeder der sich
wissenschaftlich auskennt weiß sowas
gibt es nie eine ein
Medikament das keine neben Verfügung hat
hat das ist ein Grundsatz der
Pharmakologie auch keine Wirkung
wissenschaftliche Autos
Menschen in der Pandemie
korrigiert
er hat es ja auch korrigiert und ich
fand viel wichtiger und im Nachhinein
jetzt zu sagen wir haben das viel zu
wenig Daten es war damals so wir wissen
das noch alles es war damals so dass die
Leute beängstigt waren ich bekommen
keine Impfung die einen ja die anderen
waren gegen die Impfung in dieser
Situation wo man ganz schnell also
normalerweise wenn Impfstoff 10 Jahre
lang entwickelt was hätte es in
Deutschland für den Aufstand gegeben
wenn man 10 Jahre gebraucht hätten und
da gab es dann natürlich auch Dinge ich
stimme Ihnen ja insofern zu dass man
wahrscheinlich der ist RKI z.B Robert
kocht und hätte viel mehr Untersuchungen
machen müssen die z.B steht auch
versucht hat zu machen
man hat versucht sehr schnell eine eine
dramatische Situation die wir die
Menschheit noch nie hatte
zu managen und das da auch mal Fehler
vorkommen würde ich zu billigen aber
Lauterbach hat sich immer bemüht die
Öffentlichkeit auch über den Stand der
Wissenschaft zu informieren das ist und
entschuldigt sich dann dafür dass er
sagt so
klarzustellen also erstens es geht nicht
um die Situation jetzt Ende November
zwei oder dezember 2020 bei der
Einführung der des Impfstoffes und die
ganze Diskussion davor da hatten wir
noch gar keine Impfstoff sondern es geht
darum oder so etwas dass ab Ende 2018
Herbst 2021 mit dem nächsten Lockdown
auf einmal diese infrage und zwar nur in
Deutschland in dieser Gewalt zu einem
dogmatischen Thema gemacht worden ist wo
sogar über impfpflichten diskutiert
worden ist es ist weder in Norwegen noch
in Schweden oder sonst wo nur in
Deutschland und Österreich kam dieses
Thema Impfpflicht auf die Leute was
völlig absurd war weil für die
Impfpflicht gab es überhaupt keine
epilologische oder sonst welche
Begründung
das ist aber nicht einfach nein die
versuchten das im Bundestag gehört nur
was nur an der CDU und Teilen der FDP
gescheitert ist die SPD und Grüne hätten
das einfach durchgezogen oder kann sich
doch kein Auto machen heute nicht
hinstellen ja das hat wollten wir ja gar
nicht äh ist ja Unsinn man kann ja seine
Bundestag reden sich noch anhören und
das ist genau das entscheidende Problem
es wurde diese Impfung in einer Art und
Weise
ideologisiert ich habe das ganze mal am
Anfang der Pandemie schon politische
Virologie genannt wo es überhaupt nicht
mehr um Medizin gehen ja aber wenn dann
auf beiden Seiten ja es gab auch
nirgends so absurde im Gegner wie in
Deutschland
nur
Einsatz noch
also dass ich ich warum konnten Jugend
auf die Schnapsidee mich mit
irgendjemanden der in einen Topf zu
werfen der vielleicht irgendein
unsinnigen Gegner wie Impfgegner gab es
nicht ganz so sicher
wir haben die Impfpflicht schon
verteidigt zu dieser Zeit würden sie das
heute mit dem Wissen von heute anders
beurteilen das ist ja immer die gleiche
Frage es gab keine Blaupause dafür das
ist die Nummer eins Nummer zwei ich
meine es geht ja hier bei Lauterbach um
was anderes und da geht es auch nicht um
die Frage Jens Spahn ja oder nein es
geht um die Frage des aktuellen
Verantwortlichen wenn ein Politiker
jemanden hinter die Fichte führt muss
ich einfach sagen gleitet die komplette
Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik darum geht
es und das ist das Problem hier
selbstverständlich kann er am Schluss
sagen oh ich habe mich geirrt ich habe
neue Erkenntnisse da ändere ich was aber
dass er sich hinstellt und sagt er
eigentlich habe ich es ja vorher gewusst
und zwar anders das ist natürlich nicht
in Ordnung ich muss auch dazu sagen es
hat mich ja Familie ja selbst auch
getroffen mein Vater war im Pflegeheim
die ersten Impfstoffe kamen November
Dezember für die Pflegeeinrichtung mein
Vater ist gestorben im Januar weil er
nicht geimpft worden ist weil es genau
eine Woche zwei zu spät war da wird man
auch nie rausfinden was jetzt alleine
das waren es andere Faktoren das wissen
wir einfach nicht das kann man nicht
sagen und zur damaligen Zeit war ich
tatsächlich der Auffassung dass man
zumindest in Pflegeeinrichtungen bei den
ganzen vulnerablen aber auch bei der
Frage derer die sie pflegen darüber
nachdenken muss ob man sie nicht
verpflichten muss zeitlich verpflichten
muss weil sie ja mit vulnerablen zu tun
haben dort eine Eindämmung vorzunehmen
nicht für alle das kann man streitig
stellen das gebe ich tun
ich würde sagen auf der
Gesundheitsminister sein
müsste er normalerweise jetzt die
Konsequenz sehen und sagen ich habe euch
damals hinter die Fichte geführt und
dann sagen das war's
lassen es geht nicht um die Frage
Formulierung gewähren gesagt das stimmt
sind müssen sie damit leben was Sie
gesagt haben aber ist natürlich Unsinn
nebenwirkungsfreies Unsinn bei jedem
Medikament bei jeder Impfung das kann
man gar nicht sagen also ich rede ja
nicht über sie und sie müssen ja auch
gar nicht zurücktreten
es geht um die Frage der Funktion von
Karl Lauterbach und bitte das ist es
jetzt natürlich doof doof das Gegenteil
einer CDU bin dann heißt ja ja das sagt
er jetzt so ich würde es bei meinen
genauso sagen und ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen auch eine Manuela Schwesig
unmöglich und bei vielen anderen auch
das schadet der politischen er hat der
ganzen Kaste das schadet uns allen wenn
nicht in diesen Funktionen konsequent
gerade liegt auch was gesagt wird und
natürlich zugibt ja das war aber so
Moment wir müssen schauen
man kann ein Wort falsch sagen wir reden
hier schon von Menschen die
Unterschieden beleidigen Leben zerstört
ist und ja darum kämpfen dafür Frank
auch Anerkennung zu bekommen und das ist
aufgrund der Datenlage zunehmend
schwieriger weil man eben nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kann und einen langen
bürokratischen Weg gehen muss damit
dieser im Schaden auch anerkannt wird
ein ganz ganz erstes Thema bei dem
vielleicht nicht einfach nur mal ein
falsches Wort fallen darf ja genau und
deswegen verstehe auch nicht sie sagten
ebenso schön naja da haben Corona also
diese Impfgegner die einer ganz komische
Behauptung aufgestellt und da musste der
Lauterbach ja mehr oder weniger sagen
das ist nebenwirkungsfrei damit nicht
gesagt er hat einen Fehler gemacht das
habe ich aber eben gesagt daraufhin
durfte im musste er das so sagen damit
die Leute okay das das mitziehen und das
finde ich eben das Schlimme wir sind in
dieser sind alles verteufelt worden
Menschen auch dass sie sagen die haben
gesagt das ist gefährlich wie kann man
sowas sagen das ist Meinungsfreiheit in
Deutschland dass Menschen Angst hatten
vor dieser Impfung dass keiner wusste
wie diese Impfung ausgeht dass keiner
Wurst und zu dir immer gesagt wenn wir
keine Impfpflicht bekommen wenn wir alle
sterben so hat es Lauterbach ich sage es
mal übertrieben immer wieder betont es
war eine Panikmache wir hatten alle
Angst ich war auch froh dass die
Impfstoff aber ich bin auch dreimal
geimpft ich habe Corona auch gehabt
wir sehen doch heute das ist doch total
Quatsch gewesen ist eine Impfung
aber wirklich
mal sagen es ist ein falsches Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich ja das
ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei uns nein
natürlich sehr schade für unsere Runde
da es geht hier in dieser Sendung und
dafür das muss ich Ihnen liebe zuschauen
und Zuschauer sagen ganz klar darum dass
wir hier eine offene Debatte führen dass
hier jeder sagen kann was er denkt
gerade das Thema der Pandemie ist ein
hoch emotionales Thema ganz ganz viele
Menschen haben gelitten und ich glaube
wir müssen alle daran arbeiten da
transparent zu werden und da auch
aufzuklären und genau das soll hier in
dieser Sendung auch passieren deswegen
finde ich es persönlich besonders schade
wenn jemand nicht mehr Teil dieser
Diskussion sein möchte das respektieren
wir ich hoffe meine gestern trotzdem
weiterhin Freude daran diese Debatte
weiterzuführen vielleicht wollen sie
aufrutschen damit ich hier nicht so
einsam Sitze das würde mich freuen von
Herr Lutz
ich finde das sehr bedauerlich denn ich
denke es ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Thema wir sprechen weiter darüber und
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass wir
darüber ganz offen diskutieren können
deswegen bedauerlich aber wir machen
weiter
du hattest das Wort du hast gerade
gesagt das muss ich auch selber noch mal
schauen was du gerade gesagt hast red
noch mal von vorne über deine Gedanken
es ging im Prinzip darum dass es viele
viele Menschen gibt die darum kämpfen
ein Impfschaden anerkannt zu bekommen
die Informationen darüber fehlen und für
die das natürlich nicht einfach nur ein
Wort war dass man falsch gesagt wurde
sondern es geht darum dass man vertrauen
auch in die Politik vielleicht dadurch
verloren hat absolut und es war ja
damals so und darum ging es mir gerade
auch ich habe jetzt die Reaktion noch
überhaupt nicht verstehen können das ist
ja einfach nur der Punkt ist weil er
sagt na ja der Lauterbach musste mehr
oder weniger lügen weil die Menschen
sich sonst nicht hätten impfen lassen
aber das ist doch das geht doch so nicht
nee aber es geht ja so nicht und am Ende
ist es ja so ähm die Menschen hatten zu
Großteil einfach wahnsinnige Angst vor
dieser Pandemie vor dieser Krankheit die
keine einschätzen konnte es war
natürlich gar keine Blaupause wir hatten
alle Angst wir waren ja alle dankbar bin
absolut aber man muss sich doch dann
ehrlich machen und wenn dann die
Wissenschaft nach und nach neue
Erkenntnisse hat dann muss man sich
ehrlich machen auch sagen Dinge falsch
gelaufen sind dass er sich jetzt ehrlich
macht ist ja gut aber dann muss auch die
Konsequenzen daraus tragen Herr
Lauterbach und das ist genau der Punkt
den hat man man hat diesen Eindruck er
sagt das jetzt so bei the way und
Aussehen wusste ich das und das waren ja
Daten aber es wäre alles nicht so
schlimm weil er eins zu 10.000 wenn
überlegt wie viel Menschen geimpft
worden sind und möglicherweise jetzt
lebenslang mit Schäden zu kämpfen haben
und man durfte ja fast gar nicht sagen
dass man nach der Impfung Schäden hatte
dann galt mir ja eben gleich als
möglicherweise Corona Leugner schwoben
oder sonst was also es Bedenken und
Ängste der Menschen durfte man ja gar
nicht mehr aussprechen und das finde ich
eben so schwierig man muss doch genau
wie das gerade gesagt haben offen mit
der Diskussionen die war aber nachher
moralisiert man durfte gar nicht mehr
Angst äußern Kritik äußern dann war mein
automatisch irgendwo auf der falschen
Seite und das finde ich halt sehr sehr
schwierig heute kriegen diese Menschen
im Nachhinein natürlich ein Stück weit
recht aber sie natürlich nichts wenn Sie
heute mit schweren Folgen zu kämpfen
statt führen wir da diese Debatte die
wir auch in dieser Sendung gerade
gemerkt haben auch schmerzhaft auch
emotional ist weil es eben um das Leben
von Menschen geht und das Schicksal von
Menschen wie viel Aufarbeitung müssen
wir da in Deutschland leisten
natürlich muss es komplett aufgearbeitet
werden auch richtig ist dass man
ehrlicherweise erst nach zehn Jahren
feststellen kann wie ein medikamen mit
damit richtig viel funktioniert das ist
alles richtig ich behaupte sogar selbst
wenn Lauterbach damals alles auf den
Tisch gelegt hätte hätte sich so vieles
nicht geändert wir hatten damals
Situationen da hieß es mir machen keine
Massenveranstaltungen mehr dann als es
etwas weniger wurde fC Köln wir lassen
nur geimpfte ins Stadion lauter solche
Dinge es gab ja auch Voraussetzungen die
man erfüllen musste um überhaupt am
Leben wieder teilzunehmen das wäre
vielleicht in new yorsen wenn man gesagt
hätte dass es kann gefährlicher sein
anders gewesen nur wir wissen doch alles
gibt auch jetzt Medikation die
gefährlich sind und trotzdem werden sie
in Anspruch genommen deshalb glaube ich
ist das gar nicht so der große
Unterschied und ich finde es auch schade
dass er gegangen ist wer aus der Tür
rausgeht muss nämlich irgendwann auch
wieder reinkommen und
vielleicht bin ich dazu sehr Demokrat
unterhalten uns dürfen unterschiedliche
Meinungen haben und jetzt sagen was
andersrum mehr Lauterbach jetzt nicht
Minister würde es nicht überbewerten
aber weil er Minister ist und weil er in
der Zeit ja auch schon da war hätte er
hätte sich nichts abgebrochen schon
damals alles sagen können und das ist
das Problem er hätte sich nichts
abgebrochen er hätte vielleicht auch
einiges verhindern können denn man muss
sagen es gab mehr oder weniger eine
mittelbare Impfpflicht die schon gesunde
Menschen dazu gedrängt hat sich impfen
zu lassen wir haben gerade hier über den
Druck gesprochen der da aufgebaut wurde
denken Sie an die Menge an wirklich
Versterbenden an Toten und wie die
gestorben sind ich glaube ich bleibe
dabei so viel anders wäre es gar nicht
geworden aus Italien noch Italien zum
Beispiel dass sie auch zum Teil eine auf
einer viel Interpretation einfach
Berufen also die das hatte gar nicht
eigentlich gar nichts mit der Dramatik
der Situation zu tun das wurde nur in
diese Bilder hinein interpretiert was
man nicht so einfach machen kann ich bin
ja der Meinung oder so etwas ob
Lauterbach zurücktritt das hat immer
etwas mit dem Rückhalt in der eigenen
Partei zu tun aber
der Bundestag natürlich ja das kann ich
unser Kopf in angucken aber der
Bundestag kann natürlich zum Beispiel
eine entitätkommission einrichten um
genau diese Aufarbeitung ein auf
politisch wissenschaftliche Ebene
einfach mal zu machen und dann müssen
wir uns jetzt wirklich etwas
bisschen wirklich Wasser in den Wein
gießen in Deutschland haben wir eine
Pandemie Politik gemacht die einfach
fachlich wissenschaftlich schlecht war
also auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Staaten es war eben so dass zum Beispiel
das war kein Zufall dass in einer
Staaten niemand über die Impfpflicht
geredet hat es natürlich gab es dort
auch Beschränkungen aber zum Beispiel
Karl Lauterbach wiederum und das hat gar
nichts damit zu tun der war ja so eine
Art nebenminister schon in Zeiten
der großen Koalition hat sehr spannend
auch Minister war offiziell der hat dann
z.B ähm hat Karl Lauterbach dem anders
technell das ist der Chef im Podologe in
Schweden hatte dem Rücktritt empfohlen
wegen der angeblich katastrophalen
schwedischen Politiker gut aber die
Schweden haben damit natürlich solche
gemacht und wir haben einen anderen Weg
beschritten nein das ist aber zum
Beispiel habe ich auch ein Artikel
darüber geschrieben durch solche und ist
einfach ein Fachbegriff durch solche und
heißt dass irgendwann einmal Zerstörer
hat das x-mal erklärt
dass jeder irgendwann mal infiziert wird
unvermeidlich gewesen und deswegen hat
sich keine durch solche Politik gemacht
sondern technell hat eine Politik
gemacht wo er einfach eine gute Abwägung
gemacht hat also zwischen
Infektionsschutz und zwischen dem
sozialen Leben den ökonomischen sozialen
und ähnlichen folgen das heißt also
Kinder und Jugendliche wurden in
Schweden zur Schule gehen dass
Homeschooling betraf höchstens genauso
Oberstufe also ich glaube wir können es
gibt noch wahnsinnig viel aufzuarbeiten
bei diesem Thema ganz kurze Pause hier
bei der viertel nach acht wir sind
gleich wieder für Sie da wir freuen uns
wenn Sie bei uns bleiben bis gleich
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und zu
viertel nach acht wir haben viel
Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich sein
das ist doch völlig Realität ich finde
diese Debatten unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Staaten wenn die
alle wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig
in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen
das funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand oder ist alles Essig als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen ich finde
aber diese gesamte Debatte die wir auch
führen auch ein bisschen verrückt das
ist nicht aufgearbeitet und das müssen
wir noch machen und das ist leider
Gottes auch ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
zurück bei viertel nach acht schön dass
Sie bei uns sind zwei Kinder haben ein
Kind ermordet das ist die Nachricht des
heutigen Tages die Deutschland viele
Fragen stellen ist die Deutschland
trauern lässt und über dieses Thema
müssen wir hier sprechen gleichzeitig
aber auch darüber dass es immer mehr
Gewalt hatten in Deutschland gibt woran
liegt das wir wollen dieser Sache immer
mehr jetzt auf den Grund gehen unser
Chefreporter Frank Schneider ist hier
bei uns im Studio Frank und du hast
viele Zahlen uns mitgebracht wir wollen
uns ganz allgemein mit dem Thema
Gewalttaten vor allem mit Messern hier
in dieser Sendung einmal nähern und du
sagst da müssen wir endlich aufwachen
denn es werden immer mehr deine Zeit
dein Thema ja genau das ist ein großes
Problem und was auch viele Innenminister
beruhigt wir haben die ersten Zahlen
jetzt am Sonntag Westfalen und auch von
der Bundespolizei und ich will einfach
mal ein paar Zahlen Vorlesen damit man
es einfach auch mal wirklich plastisch
sieht die haupttaten sind in diesem Jahr
also im letzten Jahr natürlich aber in
diesem Jahr sind die Zahlen
veröffentlicht worden
37 Prozent nach oben gegangen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Körperverletzungen
24 Prozent Mord und Totschlag 23 Prozent
wir hatten in der Stadt wie Essen allein
im letzten Jahr 275 Messerangriffe die
Bundespolizei sagt auch jeden Tag ein
Messerangriff den Zügen in Bahnhöfen und
erschreckend ist besonders auch und das
passt ja leider auf dramatische Weise zu
dem Fall aus Freudenberg es ist eben so
dass die Kinder und Jugendlichen
überproportional beteiligt sind wir
haben bei 500.000 Tatverdächtige
Nordrhein-Westfalen 100.000 also jeder
fünfte unter 21 und davon noch mal 20%
unter 14 also Kinder straf unmündige
Kinder und auch da z.B eine Zahl aus
Essen in Essen wohnen im letzten Jahr
936 kinderstraffällig man kann auch
außer mit dem Jugendamt dem überhaupt
nicht begegnen und ich glaube wir haben
ja gerade über Corona diskutiert auch
Corona hat er sicherlich eine Rolle
gespielt wir haben immer gehört von
überfüllten Kinder und Jugendpsychiatrie
und ich glaube dass das auch mit eine
Folge ist dieser Zeit Kinder nicht in
der Schule keine sozialen Kontakte
Konflikte konnten nicht erklärt werden
und ich glaube da muss ganz ganz
dringend was passieren und eben nicht
nur von Polizei und Justiz sondern eben
auch von Sozialarbeitern Kinder töten
Kinder das ist so ein brutales Thema das
so im Herzen weh total dass unser
Psychiater uns verlassen hat und man
möchte natürlich auch gerne über die
Hintergründe sprechen Frank wie erklärst
du der auch diesen generellen Anstieg
die Zahlen die du uns mitgebracht hast
was sind die Hintergründe woher kommen
diese erschreckenden Zahlen ja da gibt
es leider nicht so diese diesen einen
Grund das ist sehr sehr viel Schicht ich
habe so mit Corona angesprochen zum
anderen kommt auch dazu junge Menschen
sind heute gar nicht mehr so in der Lage
Konfliktlösung zu betreiben die haben
gar nicht mehr die Möglichkeit Konflikte
vernünftig zu klären es ist nicht wie
früher in der Schule da ging man nach
Hause und hatte erstmal Distanz heute
durch Social Media sondern im
permanenten Konflikt im permanenter
Kommunikation aber auch negativer
Kommunikation es entstehen
Drucksituationen dazu kommt auf der
Straße es wird immer mehr in Gruppen
tritt man auf man will auch Messer als
männlichkeitssymbol teilweise durch
Migration verwende dann öffnen sich
andere um sich zu schützen und dass ein
riesengroßes Problem denn wenn man ein
Messer dabei hat dann setzt man es eben
auch im schlimmsten Fall ein und viele
unterschätzen dass ein Messerstich eben
tödlich sein kann auch schon den
Oberschenkel da wird eine Arterie
verletzt oder ähnliches und dann ist
dieser Stich eben tödlich und ich glaube
das ist eine Entwicklung da muss einfach
die Politik massiv begegnen und wie
gesagt das ist nicht nur ein
polizeiliches Thema oder das Justiz
gerade bei straf-univer Justiz machen
die kann ja gar nichts machen ich glaube
das sind Schulen gefordert da ist sind
Sozialarbeiter von Jugendämter gefordert
Städte sofort Kommunen gefahren und alle
müssen dadurch an einem Strang ziehen
denn es ist eine dramatische Entwicklung
und nur zu sagen naja nach Corona die
sind wieder mehr draußen die Zahlen
gehen hoch das hilft nicht denn die
Zahlen die haben sich teilweise
verdoppelt auch auf Spielplätzen gibt es
jedes Jahr tausende von Straftaten es
gibt sie auf dem Schulweg auf dem
Schulhof und das sind Zahlen die sind
deutlich höher als vor Corona das zeigt
das ist eine insgesamt Entwicklung der
jetzt unbedingt sofort begegnet werden
in der Tasche dazu wird auch oft an
imiert schon was einmal ein Beispiel
rausgesucht von einem Lied von einem
sorgen den hören Kinder und Jugendliche
mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag darauf
und runter das sind kann man befürchten
dann Vorbilder für manche Kinder und
manche Jugendliche haben einmal rein
[Musik]
und deswegen nehmen sie mir wieder mein
Geld lass ihn ein Schwert oder
gleichschenkt und ich habe gar keinen
Bock mich hin und Schuld zu waschen
Wecker alle meine Jungs
kein Grund nicht zu lachen keiner von
euch schafft es gar Simon tot zu machen
im Gefängnis aber produziert auch die
ein oder anderen Hits heißt Kinder und
Jugendliche kaufen das einfach auch und
nehmen sich vielleicht so ein Rapper
auch als Vorbild und auch seine Texte
sind für sie aber doch mehr Realität
gerade eben haben wir gehört ganz klar
die Politik darf da nicht die Augen
verschließen verschießt die Politik so
auf der Vorwürfe auch die Augen vor dem
Tätern dass man nicht zu sehr darüber
sprechen will
es kommt die politische Antwort das ist
eine so umfassende Sache die kann man
nicht auf eines fokussieren kann wenn
sie bei der Situation anfangen das ist
schon passiert ist also bei den
repressiven Maßnahmen ja klar dann muss
man einmal schauen ob
Staatsanwaltschaften oft oder zu oft
einstellen die sind weisungsgebunden das
kann ein Minister in Justizminister
bestimmt das ist die eine Sache vor
allem gerade in Bezug auch auf
Rettungskräfte auf die blaulichtfamilie
Royal in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat das
gefordert auch gemacht damit alles zur
Anlage gebracht das ist dann wenn es
passiert ist
das kann abschreckend sein muss es auch
sein und das muss auch entsprechend ja
mit einer Strafe versehen sein die
wehtut es muss einem klar sein jetzt
geht es aber entscheidender darum was
passiert denn vorher und da gehört
zunächst einmal dazu
dass man mehr Polizei auf die Straße
bringt das ist in jedem Bundesland ein
riesen Problem und das war es die ganzen
Jahre hinweg jetzt hat man mal 5000
Bundespolizisten mehr eingestellt sie
wissen selbst wie im Moment bei der
Frage der der Flüchtlingsbewegungen
schon die Außengrenzen nicht geschützt
werden können wie wollen Sie das
Darstellen sie brauchen mehr Personal
das muss auch besser geschult sein und
sie müssen auch da sein und weil das
nicht reicht mit mehr Personal müssen
Sie mehr Videoüberwachung zulassen das
ist selbstverständlich ich frag mich
immer wovor habe ich Angst wenn ich an
einem Bahnhof vorbei laufe dass mich da
einer filmt wenn ich das weiß dass er
mich filmt und wenn ich weiß dass das
nach einer gewissen Zeit vernichten muss
also das entscheidende dann kann mir das
doch egal sein also das sind die zweiten
Maßnahmen und die dritte viel
entscheidendere ja es ist eine
gesellschaftspolitische Problem
Informatik Eltern scheinen sich nicht
mehr ausreichen damit zu befassen was
ihre Kinder tun und wenn sie es tun weiß
ich auch nicht ob Kinder nicht in
anderen Umfeldern beispielsweise in der
Schule und sonst wo im übrigen fällt ja
viel zu viel Unterricht auch aus da kann
man auch noch viele andere Dinge tun
sich dort kommunikativ in eine Richtung
bewegen die Gewaltverherrlichung
mitbringt wir haben auch eine ganz
andere Situation wenn ich mir alleine
meine Kinder anschaut die sind jetzt
allerdings auch schon 22 und 20 die
spielen heute spiele das hat also wir
haben früher auch Spiele gespielt auf
der Straße heute sind die am Computer ja
so also ich will das jetzt nicht falsch
verstanden wir sind alles okay kann man
alles tun aber man muss natürlich dann
auch schauen was wir da gespielt wer
lässt das zu und wer kontrolliert was da
gespielt wird bei der Musik kann ich
Ihnen nur eines sagen
ich persönlich habe nichts gegen Rap ich
höre nur Heavy Metal aber das kann man
ja auch hören nur wenn es solche verwalt
gewaltverherrlichten Titel gibt mit
diesem Texten dann finde ich gehören die
außenprogramm das kann nicht sein dass
wir sowas einfach noch als Kunst oder
Musik mit zulassen wenn es solche Dinge
gibt da muss man strikter dran also ich
werde ein Satz zu sagen wir diskutieren
in Deutschland über Leila ob das möglich
ist jugendgefährdend ist alles ganz
schrecklich und solche Lieder dürfen
dann auf den Markt und das ist etwas was
ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe auch gefährlich sein man kann
leider ja doof wenn man muss es eben
auch nicht hören aber das ist keine
Musik die Menschen haben sondern solche
Musik und da wird Gewalt absolut
verherrlicht und da ist es ja auch toll
wenn man eben einen Knast gesessen aber
man ist gangster rapper man ist was und
das ist leider Gottes für ganz viele
junge Menschen die teilweise auch
gesellschaftlich abgegangen sind
abgehängt sind die gar nicht wissen
wohin geht die Reise für mich dann
suchen Sie sich diese Idole und träumen
davon irgendwann auch so ein cooler oder
nicht vermeiden nicht verhindern das ist
so weil die Menschen schon immer gab
aber das werden einfach viel zu viele
Kinder die falschen Vorbilder sollte man
die Lieder verbieten sollte man mehr
Kameras aufstellen sind hier Lösungen
für sie dabei leider kann ich mein Vater
nicht fragen der schon lange gestorben
ob ich damals die falschen Vorbilder
gehabt habe auch die Idee zum Beispiel
irgendwelche heutzutage noch
irgendwelche Lieder zu verbieten ich
weiß nicht also es gibt ja immer noch
diese Zentralstelle zur Prüfung
jugendgefährdender Schriften ähm es gibt
eigentlich immer so die Motivation dass
das dann besonders interessant wird und
Leila hätte glaube ich kein Menschen
interessiert
Diskussion gegeben hätte aber ähm die
Sänger haben sich gefreut glaube ich
eine jugendlicheren heiße hieß sie ich
kann mich erinnern ich habe darüber sehr
viele Talkshow Rezension damals
geschrieben und er hat mir exakt
dieselbe Diskussion 1:1 dieselbe
Diskussion steigende Zahlen da ging es
dann so gegen dieses gegen diese
liberale Vorstellung von von Strafe
nämlich gar nicht zu straffen und jetzt
frage ich mich natürlich in diese ganzen
zehn Jahren was hat sich dort geändert
also ich glaube zum Beispiel sehr viele
Gerichte heute nicht mehr diese Larifari
Haltung haben die versuchen auch die
Zeiten zu verkürzen und so weiter das
hat natürlich besser geworden ja das
muss man erstmal und dann könnte man ja
dann nachvollziehen so wie sie das auch
versucht haben zu schildern was ist
eigentlich jetzt im Laufe dieser 10-15
Jahre noch dazu gekommen ein Problem und
natürlich verändert sich auch die
Lebenswelt von Jugendlichen merke ich
bei meinen eigenen Kindern also ich habe
vier davon und natürlich spielen die
antibi alle Spiele ich habe nicht mit
Videospielen gespielt weil äh zu meiner
Zeit gab sie noch gar nicht also aber
das ist eine Situation daran kann man
nichts ändern nein aber was woran die
etwas ändern können das ist natürlich
schon z.B eine Situation dass das
jugendliche und in Schulen funktionieren
das Kindergärten funktionieren und und
ganz plastisches Beispiel was ich Ihnen
sagen erzählen kann
gibt's zum Beispiel so eine Gruppe von
jungen Afghanen die vom Jugendamt von
der Jugendhilfe betreut werden ja die
warten sechs Monate darauf dass sie
überhaupt beschult werden ja klar gibt
keine Schule für die ja was machen die
die ganze Zeit die musste in irgendeiner
Form dann gehen die Betreuer mit den
einmal in der Woche Fußball spielen und
kümmern sich wirklich um die aber selbst
so etwas Elementares wie zum Beispiel
Schulunterricht findet da nicht statt
und ich weiß nicht wie das hier in
Berlin wie das hier in Berlin ist ich
wohne ja in der Westfälischen Provinz
der funktioniert das vielleicht noch
besser aber wenn wir solche elementaren
Dinge nicht hinbekommen ja dann brauchen
wir über diesen ganzen anderen Kram
glaube ich erstmal gar nicht zu reden
ein Problem haben wir hier in Berlin
aber auch in der Provinz das ist die
Energieerzeugung und damit können wir
jetzt zu unserem nächsten Thema das ist
nämlich ihr Thema Herr Waldorf sie sagen
ganz klar lange ist es ja nicht mehr 15
April dann werden die verbleibenden
akads vom Netz genommen und dann könnte
es düster aussehen das ist ihr Thema
jetzt
ja ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass
wir uns in der Energiepolitik im Moment
auf dem Holzweg befinden es ist vieles
was keine Logik in sich wirkt vor allem
gerade auch im Hinblick darauf dass uns
erst die Augen so richtig geöffnet
wurden durch diese schlimme Katastrophe
in der Ukraine und dem Wegfall dieser
gasbrücke die wir bis dahin hatten ich
kann nur für
diesen diesen Standort in Deutschland
dann erhalten mit unserem Wohlstand mit
der Sicherheit und auch mit bezahlbarer
Energie wenn ich dafür sorge dass ich in
einem breiten Energiemix diese
energieerzeugungsquellen nutze die ich
brauche und dafür brauche ich vor allem
auch grundlastfähigen Strom
grundlastfähige Energieform wir leisten
uns im Moment die Situation dass wir im
November und im Dezember bei einer
notwendigen grundlastleistung von 60 GB
die wir brauchen in Deutschland 20 GB
verstromt haben aus Gas trotzdem Gas im
Moment nicht so leicht zu haben ist wenn
sie mit großen indust die Verbänden
reden wenn sie mit Industrie reden wie
beispielsweise BASF merken die immer
mehr es ist nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig
was hier läuft wir selbst sehen es an
den Abrechnungen der Stadtwerke und
deshalb stellt sich für mich die Frage
wie man so unlogisch drangehen kann und
sagen kann dass 10 bis 15 Prozent der
grundlastfähigen Erzeugung aus
Kernenergie aus den sicheren
Kernkraftwerken die seit 60 Jahren in
Deutschland laufen und bei denen nichts
passiert ist jetzt zu einer Abschaltung
führen sollen im Gegenteil ich bin der
Meinung man müsste die drei bereits
abgeschalteten aber noch mit einer
Betriebserlaubnis versehenen Kraftwerke
wieder ans Netz bringen und ich habe
mich da sehr intensiv mit befasst wir
müssen auch den Mut haben die small
modular regulators die neuen
Kraftwerke die kleinen Kraftwerke auch
in Deutschland einzuführen wir werden
auf Dauer kann Energie brauchen für die
Grundsicherung für die Grundlast
Auslosung wie klar ist da ihre Partei
positioniert sie haben jetzt gerade ein
ganz ein ganz flammenden Monolog
gehalten aber man hat ja ihrer Partei
noch nicht ganz klar rausgehört ja wir
sind auch für den Neubau von AKWs werden
andere Länder Frankreich beispielsweise
das ja machen so weit geht man aber
nicht Beispiel ist ja beispielsweise
auch Finnland wenn Sie meine Partei
ansprechen
finanzieren in der Schweiz ist es
zwischenzeitlich anders als ich mich mit
dem Thema näher befasst habe gebe ich
frank und frei zu oder das ist jetzt
auch erst ein halbes Jahr her weil die
Forderung neue Kraftwerke zu bauen ja
noch mal einen anderen Spin bekommt da
haben die mir in Karlsruhe gesagt die
ganzen Professoren lassen Sie die Finger
weg das kriegen sie in Deutschland nie
im Leben durch die Leute werden das alle
ablehnen dass die hat das hat eine
negativen Touch das geht nicht ja aber
da gilt doch das gleiche wie bei ganz
den ganzen anderen Diskussionen die wir
haben man muss sich doch erstmal Kunde
machen man muss mal erklärt bekommen
über was wir reden man muss die Risiken
sehen sie sind viel sicherer diese
Kernen Energie Reaktoren also nein es
hilft nur nichts wenn Sie das sagen weil
sie kriegen keine Zustimmung ja und
genau das ist ja Punkt wer nicht dicke
Bretter bohrt wird nie durchkommen und
wir werden jetzt alle bei unseren
Abrechnungen Querschnitt feststellen
dass wir ans Ende kommen und das gilt
vor allem jetzt nicht für diejenigen wie
wir hier sitzen die sich das irgendwie
noch leisten können aber gehen sie bitte
mal in die Bereiche gerade in
Mietverhältnissen wo das nicht mehr
funktionieren wird so wer zahlt denn das
am Ende das zahlen wir über die
Quersubventionierung von
Unterstützungsleistungen so kann ein
Staat nicht funktionieren und gehen wir
auch mal direkt vor ihrer
Hausversicherung das selber auch
angesprochen wie BASF wartet abzieht
viele Arbeitsplätze ins Ausland was
bedeutet das was fürchten sie da auch
für die
Besonderheit dass die natürlich auch für
die Grund für die Grundstoffe die sie
erzeugen Gas brauchen aber natürlich
haben die 2,2 Milliarden Euro mehr an
Energiekosten gehabt im letzten Jahr es
ist das ist das größte chemische Werk
der Welt mit 35.000 Arbeitsplätzen in
Deutschland in Ludwigshafen aber das
heißt ja auch wenn die jetzt ihre
Investitionen alle nach China verlagern
dass es hier nicht mehr interessant sein
wird und Sie bekommen von Martin Bruder
dem CEO gesagt LNG das können sie
vergessen das kann keiner bezahlen im
Verhältnis wettbewerbsfähiger Kosten und
dann kann man natürlich sagen wir bauen
noch eine ganze Menge Windanlagen und
Solar bin ich mit allem einverstanden
sie werden aber nie grundlastfähig und
sie werden auch niemals das erzeugen
können was die Kernenergie jetzt bringt
bei einem Betrag von 10 bis 15%
Grundlast mehr ist es ja gar nicht aber
die brauchen sie und wenn Sie das jetzt
abschalten ja wo wollen sie es denn her
nehmen auch vW lübberding baut ein neues
Werk lieber in den USA oder in China was
befürchten sie für den Industriestandort
Deutschland ja das ist spannende Frage
weil dieser die
industrialisierungsprozesse muss man
sich ja nicht so vorstellen dass
schlagartig alles aufhört sondern das
sind immer merkt das nur ein Zurückgehen
Investition das ist genau der Punkt und
da ist BASF und einige andere die sagen
natürlich ganz klar unter diesen
Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland können
wir hier nicht mehr rentabel
Wirtschaften vor allem im
internationalen Vergleich das ist ein
bisschen Protest keine ganzen Sache ist
dass wir nach nur so 90 wirklich 20
Jahre lang oder 15 Jahre lang gebraucht
haben um uns an Europäisierung DDR
deutsche Einheit Globalisierung
anzupassen das haben wir dann wirklich
sehr gut geschafft wir haben unsere
industriellen Kerne wirklich erhalten
die haben wahnsinnig gut funktioniert
die das ganze alte Thema preisliche
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit war völlig weg und
jetzt auf einmal holt uns das ganze
Thema andersherum wieder ein was ich bei
der Sie Fragen möchte ich meine ich habe
hier so ein paar Spatzen in Berlin und
die erzählen mir immer die nächste
Koalition wird eine von der CDU mit den
Grünen
und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage wir
wollen sie eigentlich dieses Konzept was
sie da haben durchsetzen mit den Grünen
in einem Koalitionsvertrag haben sie
ähnliche Probleme bekommen wie jetzt die
FDP und ich finde ich wenn immer gegen
die Atomkraft gewesen ich war in 80er
Jahren im Brokdorf und so etwas hat auch
mit gegen demonstriert und ich glaube
was ich ja so faszinierend finde ist
nachdem wir zehn Jahre lang Energiewende
gemacht haben muss man einfach
konzentrieren die funktioniert nicht das
heißt
ich bin na ich gehe nicht mehr ich gehe
grundsätzlich nicht mehr auf die Straße
also aber der aber der wirklich wichtige
Aspekt ist einfach wenn man das jetzt
eingestehen musste ist nicht
grundlastfähig also zum Beispiel ganz ne
Ideen die wir in den 80er Jahren hatten
was Energiewende betreibt hatte einen
entscheidenden Punkt das war nicht
Windräder und Sonnenkollektoren und
Blockheizkraftwerke oder so sondern
Energie Ansparung Effizienzsteigerung ja
aber da hatten wir noch kein Internet
und ich weiß nicht was alles und äh und
das heißt diese wir sind wirklich sehr
viel effizienter geworden auch in der
Volkswirtschaft mit der im Verhältnis zu
Energieproduktion oder zum
Energieverbrauch aber wir haben so viele
zusätzliche Bedarfe produziert dass das
alles davon gefressen wird und die
Koalitionsfrage möchte ich schon noch
mal gerne beantwortet bekommen die CDU
und die Grünen das was die Spatzen so
von den Dächern pfeifen würde das denn
funktioniert also ich bin ja immer noch
der Meinung dass man wenn man reelle und
logische Dinge sagt dass die auch auf
einen fruchtbar und Boden fallen können
sie haben was ganz wichtig gesagt wir
haben im Moment einen Verbrauch in
Deutschland von 650 Terawattstunden in
komplett so auf
49/249 ist projiziert 1,5 Millionen
Terawattstunden das sind Steigerung
E-Mobilität Daten viele andere Dinge
dann unsere ganzen Wärmepumpen die der
liebe Herr Harbig jetzt da bei jedem
durchsetzen will mit diesen ganzen
heizungsdingen welch ein Irrsinn über
was wir da reden wenn ich also weiß ich
brauche mehr Elektrizität muss überlegen
wo ich die her hole die kann ich jetzt
bei uns aus dem Nachbarland Frankreich
holen die kann ich auch aus der
Tschechei holen die kann ich aus
saporicia holen die kann ich überall her
holen vielleicht mache ich es aber
anders und überlege mal was war die
Stärke immer in Deutschland Forschung
und Entwicklung und dann fangen wir mal
an diese wirklich ausgereifte bei uns
entwickelte Technologie die damals den
Nachteil hatte dass sie einen Haufen an
ja an eine strahlendem Schrott
hinterlässt was heute aber nicht mehr
der Fall ist dass man das auch in die
Köpfe bringt und wenn Sie das fragen wie
das an der Koalition ist da mögen sie
sich jetzt wundern ich kämpfe zunächst
mal immer in meinen eigenen Reihen dafür
dass erstmal die Union so stark wird
dass ohne sie nicht regiert werden kann
erstens zweitens welche Koalition am
Schluss zustande kommt haben wir in den
letzten Jahren erlebt hat nie jemand
Projekt sein können weil es immer anders
kam
wird meiner Frau
und drittens weiß ich auch von grünen
das dass die durchaus darüber nachdenken
in diese Richtung auch weiterhin sich zu
informieren zu entwickeln jetzt muss man
den Grünen ein Kompliment machen eines
lasse ich
informieren tun sie sich schon also sie
glauben es gäbe
die dafür wären neue Atomkraftwerke
deshalb ist auch auf europäischer Ebene
ja so mitgenommen worden aber das heißt
ja nicht dass ich hier nicht über eine
Überzeugung kämpfen muss und
Entschuldigung bitte hätten sie erwartet
dass der Herr Habig zu einem Scheich
nach Katar fährt oder hätten Sie
erwartet dass der Herr Scholz in Kanada
erzählt wir bauen eine Leitung eine
Gasleitung von West nach Ost Kanada die
die gar nicht bauen wollen oder hätten
Sie erwartet dass wir am Ende des Tages
eine Annalena bärbung sehen die die
Leopard 2 Panzer in der Ukraine fahren
lassen will irgendwann kommt die Logik
auch bei den Grünen an
können Sie sich das vorstellen grüne die
sagen ja wir brauchen neue akadem
Nordrhein-Westfalen der funktioniert ja
schwarz grün trotz da ist man so ein
bisschen in der Realität angekommen und
auch bei der migrationsfall wir sehen
jetzt grüne Landräte die plötzlich sagen
die das geht so nicht weiter ich sage
immer so wenn Realität auf Politik
trifft dann entstehen plötzlich Lösungen
und auch Kompromisse die man sich vorher
nicht vorstellen konnte und ich gehe
fest davon aus dass die Grünen Umdenken
werden müssen denn wir werden genau wie
das gerade gehört haben so viel
Strombedarf bekommen über die E-Autos
wir sollten jetzt keine Heizlüfter
anschalten in 10 Jahren wollen wir 15
Millionen E-Autos laden ohne die
Atomkraftwerke wir jetzt noch haben das
kann und wird so nicht funktionieren und
ich glaube und hoffe dass dieses
ideologisch verblendete mal aufhört dass
man sich öffnet und gemeinsam überlegt
und wenn es nur eine Brückentechnologie
ist wie können wir die nächsten 15 20
Jahre so sauber überbrücken dass dieser
Standort in Deutschland der Wohlstand
noch bleibt
aktuellen Regierung eher schwierig aus
dass sich da die Grünen jetzt öffentlich
ich will noch mal bei dem Punkt nämlich
bleiben ich glaube einfach das für die
Grünen z.B der Atomausstieg ist eine der
ähm Glaubenssätze also die die könnten
glaube ich in einer tiefe
Identitätskrise stürzen ähnlich wie
vielleicht unsere katholischen Kollegen
mit so einer Situation schon umzugehen
weil da bleibt glaube ich effektiv nicht
mehr sehr viel von den Grünen und ihrem
ursprünglichen Ursprungsmythos zurück
ich plädiere einfach dafür dass man
einfach diese sechs Reaktoren
tatsächlich wieder ans Netz bringt und
das mal zehn Jahre lang eine Art
Moratorium macht genau um auf gewisse
Probleme wie zum Beispiel fehlende
Speicherkapazitäten bei den erneuerbaren
Energien um das einfach mal auszuloten
und das bedeutet dass dann kann auch die
da können auch die Grünen mit leben weil
sie dann natürlich den Atomausstieg eben
nur vertagen aber das ist halt das
politische Spiel man muss irgendwie sein
Gesicht warten das was sie aber das was
ihr aber sagen ist ja auch die reelle
Situation selbst wenn man heute der
Meinung wäre man müsste neue direkt
installieren wird das Jahr 10 Jahre
dauern wir können jetzt mal heute kaufen
das können sie tun aber sie werden die
zehn Jahre brauchen deshalb ist das von
ihrem Zeit Strang den sie nehmen mit der
Forderung zu sagen die sechs jetzt noch
mit Betriebserlaubnis versehenen Anlagen
werden weitergeführt der richtige Weg
also dem kann ich mich voll anschließen
und dann müssen wir ein bisschen Mut
haben und einfach mal Forschung und
Entwicklung nach vorne
muss ich leider sagen bitte endet an
dieser Stelle wir beenden diese Sendung
ich danke ganz herzlich meinen drei
verbleibenden Gästen einen haben wir auf
der Strecke verloren danke auch noch mal
an der dritte und früher verlassen hat
und vor allem vielen herzlichen Dank an
Sie liebe zuschauen und Zuschauer wir
sehen uns wenn Sie mögen morgen wieder
acht bis dann
[Musik]